I think he's trying to collect go into
the portal and that's what he's doing in
here
Oh God this is one we got our grip as
head
that's comforted comforting if the
monster come is sacrifice dead oh oh oh
[ __ ] what there's no going back now
no it's coming after me oh [ __ ] man it's
the thing that chased us before ok let's
think fast what ok go in here
it's a dragon right yeah it's the dragon
thingy ok nothing in here what the hell
okay is something there press that I
don't know what it does I'm stuck what
what's going on what's going on stand
here
what no doesn't work hey this is
creeping me out
yeah same here what's going on
pick it up [ __ ] at 24 of those I can't i
grip us head no [ __ ] what is this
this is screwing here good bike
oh it didn't follow me all the way thank
God
ha
no um what if I had I can't
okay there's there just got to be
something in there oh wait there's
another door uh-huh
oh [ __ ] there's a note here probably yep
I always read them like this so the
monster doesn't sneak up on me factories
of August 1839 it's not fair
I'm not to blame I've been manipulated
by that demon he played my guilty
conscience and duped me into facing a
shadow alone
inspiring man
he expects me to meet my death as he
steals power beyond imagination Oh
Alexander I will kill you for what you
have done
if only the shadow had caught me in
London or Algeria I wouldn't have to
suffer this humiliation huh you made me
a murderer
a monster so that's why you wanted to
forget I merely await my death and too
weak to press on I can hardly stand as -
fail me I cannot see those crying threat
in tears yes and yankin of the men I
taught you if only I could wipe my fear
away as a kid with them
so we finally found out but we kind of
knew anyway
creepy stuff going on let's press this
ouch oh I think I sacrificed my blood
yeah you know it kind of reminds me of
myself I don't know what's it called
lean English you know to sleep get girl
the what sleeping girls ah yeah who
falls asleep from a soothing wheel
Sleeping Beauty is equal Sleeping Beauty
I don't know I think so yeah
but I know what you mean but I don't you
know what it's called in English either
Sleeping Beauty what am I supposed to do
do you have any ideas
yeah you saw the wooden door come fruit
I can't open it won't budge
yeah oh [ __ ] I think my son already went
down yeah I mean snidely get it up uh
I'm insane insanely good-looking if you
know what I mean I'm just kidding okay
it's good we're back you see now it went
back to something happen it was that
there before
maybe I just admit let's try that if I
stop touch nothing
I think we're going to do the same thing
but over here so we're just going to
stand at this press set and then stand
at this altar yeah
and my son he goes down again and that
thing appears yeah oh [ __ ]
monster yeah I sounded like it I don't
know though just I'm gonna get up Daniel
oh [ __ ] now the goo is here ouch
in your salad made she's going here what
do you say yeah sorry oh there's no
going back
oh that looks great I can hear my
heartbeat orb chamber you want to go
there
holy moly
this oh if it wasn't for Alexander he
would still be innocent and be able to
die so true that
true that oh wow what the hell is going
on here step turn to supernatural I was
wondering we're gonna show up and I
convinced you to run some errands
oh there is is everything nice and clear
have I the villain good
but hardly
are you so blind that you see no go
being me what's your grip my you know
grip now that's Alex honor huh
it looks like a spirit thank yes oh [ __ ]
the pilings unstable and virtual falling
over a still distant
or do I have to tighten up I have
nothing to use it on
see if it doesn't
there's no time um I saw a hammer then
we're ignited light
the [ __ ] is going on I hate the music
it's horrible
yeah I can't hear anything oh yeah I
could do this I was just I just had to
hold it down
the thing is sorry I breaking the mood
here but when we were supposed to use
his head do you remember that yeah when
we go through the portal but isn't that
the portal
I don't get it
oh it has an opening oh oh we [ __ ] up
ha ha I get it I get it
became as I know yeah I get it now walls
my greatest triumph I know you never
but we're killing except now yeah you
think I was afraid fleeing brennenburg
quite the contrary
I knew it was my purva tree health I
made to wash away my sins yet
[ __ ]
there's no denying the things I've done
but I have paid my tribute I gave them
that awful man others did us leaving
brennenburg let's exit yay
we're free I hope or are we just insane
what about the head I'm going to explain
it in a second basically we were
supposed to wait for the portal to open
and then throw his head in and then ruin
it that way we save the Reaper I just
you know so we get so we got a different
ending and try that ending I'm not
recording there we go okay so oh you got
a meeting I see a room
tell them is everything nice and clear
now yeah we're going to wait for the
portal to open apparently good yeah
portal has not open yet but
ouch that you see no go being mean or
evil in Agrippa
is Agrippa and important K um I don't
know
I guess the one is open now
and I guess we had to gotta wait for the
other two or something they ain't got a
bit quick close it yeah I better be
ready for it
god this music so horrible
yeah
I look at his head it looks so funny
it's not open yet still
exact I'm dead you think I have to push
the one down the one that's already been
huh
because it does seem like he's kind of
waiting for me to do something it should
let's wait one more minute okay
I don't know
or should we I mean nothing is happening
are they spinning faster
so I can see what's in like one fps
yeah we had to wait
isn't beautiful oh portal will open very
soon
and ready
still not open without oh there it is
week yeah I did it
okay so that was a good ending
apparently I think this is your room
ouch and then we died instead or maybe
we died either way I don't know there's
a rose leaves
what's going on oh I can walk look this
[ __ ] stay still I'm gonna walk over here
now just kidding
there is do you see you Maya a great ice
hockey he deserves so much more
please help you I know you can
dog very Daniel I think he's saving us
all right
I grew up I was a bro after all
yeah it's pretty cool game I think those
for their own landings I don't I'm not
sure I'm not gonna try another one we
didn't get a single answer uh yes we did
I don't know
I think I thought it was an awesome game
actually yeah but
no Jam and the remaining questions I
don't know kind of like
what Alexander really wanted I mean I
guess what was behind the portal yeah
this [ __ ] was that mr. yeah what
happened to the shadow but we tend to
knew who we was but I don't we don't
know like lucky well he was just the
guardian of the warp
oh yeah of course yeah
he was not enough but like why was he
the guard named the orb like who sent
him or something that I guess actually
bill Corkery as i gripa I really want to
google how he looks he's gotta look so
weird
he had the most weird voice ever
what are you doing Daniel commissioning
shot yeah here it's the dang that he's
gotta be Swedish right yeah I never
heard any Swedish guy called sweating
though
we'll find games special thanks to
lifting game grass Johnson it's gotta be
Swedish as well well not necessarily
with what on why do I knew the end Oden
through in lay Ely ordinary Ornella
something I don't know I think we're
done
ya can't do anything wait wait free
thank God I never have to play this game
anymore I'm so glad it's over seriously
I honestly feel like I could put this on
my CV like so what have you done in your
life
well I've completed a Misha the Dark
Descent oh yeah that can handle a
situation yeah exactly
but they're gonna ask me that like are
you good in stressful situation [ __ ]
I finished amnesia they're like oh my
lord
probably not but seriously this was the
scariest scariest thing I've voluntarily
done at least I think I'm pretty sure
actually and I'm pretty sure I'll never
play anything as here as this this is
game that the school could ask you to do
like yeah I have to do this just gave me
free week yeah exactly that's something
like that and then uh I also feel like
it's like I would become more you know
less scared after playing this game
because I'd get used to it something I
feel like I have gained nothing from
playing this game I feel like something
has been taken away from me instead like
I've lost something now or two playing
this I don't know
and I guess final words would be thank
you for watching and yeah thanks a lot
for watching it's a lot of parts to
watch I think this gotta be like the
forties but still something hopefully it
was enjoyable for you as well and I'm
gonna sign off
do you find it say anything no no okay
well see you later guys